i've known this man quite some time uh
he was in charge of the new york jets
organization grocery shopping for uh
many a moon
2001-2012 and then he spent a few years
the organization of the miami dolphins
now he's on the worldwide leader in
sports joining us on the mercedes-benz
vans hotline and phone line right now is
our friend mike tannenbaum how are you
mike
good rich great to be with you how's it
going i'm in a mood mike i'm not gonna
i'm in a mood
joe flacco starting for the jets mike
second straight year
uh
what what gives i'll give you the floor
on why you think they made this decision
go for it yeah
yeah interesting decision rich i didn't
see that one coming you know i like most
of us most in the football world were
really encouraged by mike white i
thought he played really well against
the colts and a couple of other
preliminary showings and thought he was
a guy that maybe they had something in
and had a bad day against buffalo which
candidly a lot of quarterbacks gonna
have
bad showings against that bill's defense
and a little little surprise that
they're going with flacco and obviously
their future is all about zach wilson i
know but uh what what could possibly be
the decision i mean you've been in
you've been in rooms where maybe
groupthink takes over or
or they sit here and they think that
they got their ass kicked in front of
their home crowd against the bills and
we don't want to do that again against
miami i mean salah basically said you
know the cover zero stuff that mike that
flacco's been there done that gives him
a better chance to win mike yeah i think
he just gave you really good insight on
what he was thinking which is if we go
back a week ago
and that's exactly what miami did blitz
their safety so middle of the fields
wide open big risk reward in terms of
defensively your you know the old saying
you're gonna live by the blitz you're
gonna die by the blitz and lamar jackson
baltimore really struggled with it
and that's the defense that coach flores
believes in and
joe flacco does have a lot more
experience than mike white and i'm sure
that was part of it it's a home game one
that i'm sure they think they can win
and
probably because of his experience
that's why they're gonna go with flacco
but kindly i was a little surprised
again mike white hasn't been perfect but
i thought he had shown enough in some of
the other games cincinnati new england
that hey let's at least give him another
opportunity here against a division
rival with a good defense because maybe
it's mike white and zach wilson moving
forward because joe flacco to me i just
don't see him being part of that team in
the future does ownership have a
decision in this process with the jets
at all i don't think so rich you know
woody johnson was very supportive when i
was there we certainly would talk about
things like the quarterback position
often but he would never mandate to say
hey let's go with flacco this week
because mike white looked against
buffalo um
he was
a listener or he was a guy that would
ask questions but never one that would
mandate who to play okay uh did you guys
ever ever sound there to try and get rid
of whatever the hell hangs over the jets
franchise did that ever happen like at
any point in time anybody that sit
around and go you know what there's
something there's something off around
here i know you made two afc
championship games in a row and that
might have been the version of that but
uh after that as we all know butt
fumbles happened everything kind of went
in a different direction so did that
ever happen mike anybody ever suggest
that with the giants
you know we tried a lot of things rich
as you know you know tebow
rex yeah yeah we we got something wrong
with tebow um but
i don't know like to me you got to be
patient and if you believe in the
process that got robert solid you
believe in the process to go get zach
wilson you got to give it time and i
know that's hard sometimes and things
are kind of bumpy right now i surely
thought they would have played better
against buffalo but
um you got to stay the course and just
live with the growing pains okay i'm
going to go i'm going to go here with
you if you don't mind mike tyler and
here's the here with rex do you know of
a single soul that's comparing mike
robert solid or rex ryan or rex to
robert salah other than rex honestly you
talk you must be around the whole jet
fandom or hear a lot you know a lot of
folks back in new york i do i haven't
heard a single one what's he talking
about what's that all about
uh yeah that one caught me you know off
guard to be candid now look max is a
commentator and he's going to say
exactly what he thinks and that's the
rex that we all know and love that i
work with for four years but yeah to
compare himself personally to uh coach
sal was uh a surprise to me now
rex is certainly entitled to his opinion
rich and obviously he hasn't been
pleased with his performance no i get it
but i don't understand it like it just
doesn't make any sense like rex look
when because you you were the one who
hired rex right mike correct back in
that day right
perfect it was so perfect because that's
exactly what the jets needed they needed
a chest pounder they need they needed to
say somebody like i'm not going to kiss
belichick's rings that's what they
needed at the time but right now what
they need is someone like salah i i
don't understand why they're like why
one has to take away from the other you
know i don't get that one i don't
totally fair and you know there is um
like i said i was surprised that he took
it to a personal level and you know rex
is going to talk about coaches and you
know be up and down on them like anybody
else and covering our sport but um i was
surprised that he made it personal all
right all right mike you're a high class
guy you know what i mean and it's just
it's just i don't know it's just we're
here again man
we're here again so what do is zach the
guy is he kenny i mean i know we haven't
seen anything yet but i mean you're
already you're already seeing other
teams with the ability to to begin to
assess who they have and
what they have jets are still sitting
here and starting joe flacco week 11
without an answer again about their
quarterback
you know you know which one thing i
would say though is i was very
disappointed what zack wilson said in
august when he was comparing himself to
hey i'm studying aaron rodgers and what
i would have said to him back then is
like look aaron rodgers is a fully
formed adult like learn how to drive a
car in the right hand lane learn the
value of a check down learn the value of
a pun aaron rodgers has made you know
he's an all-time great who made a lot of
mistakes and learned along the way and i
think the zack rules that we heard last
week i thought that was a marked
improvement i thought it was a much more
humble
and one that realized that playing
quarterback in pro football takes a
minute and i never ever root for
injuries to anybody but with that said i
think him getting hurt is a real benefit
because now we could sit back
watch and learn and that's candidly
something that he needed to do and let's
see him like we know rich he can make
the flash plays we've seen it we saw it
in the tennessee game what we need to
see now is hey check the ball down or a
punt is a good play mike tannenbaum here
on the rich eisen show i guess it's the
mike tannenbaum bowl in metlife uh the
dolphins
uh are are walk me through what you
think happened
with uh stephen ross and desean watson
the night that they met what do you
think happened
with that yeah i don't yeah i don't know
if they met but i will say this i think
looking into it was a really smart move
by the dolphins and here's why
when you have the ability to talk to a
player under the tampering rules and
i'll give you a perfect example rich
once we got permission to talk to brett
favre when we were at the jets it took
us about three weeks for us to convince
them to come to us over tampa bay
it didn't work out now i think that's
been well reported but here's what i
will say
if and when in march they decide that
hey we still want to go over go get
deshawn watson they have a competitive
advantage because you know houston's
going to call all the other teams
philadelphia denver and anybody else
that could have an interest in watson
and now at least miami has a foundation
of a relationship so even though it
didn't work out short term i could
understand why a team who has questions
about their quarterback would look into
watson that's different than making the
decision to acquire him because
obviously this is a very complicated
situation so
i think the story is not over because
watson hasn't been traded and
next march when this heats up again
miami's starting well ahead of their
competitors are you in the uh two is
just a guy camp in the evaluation of
tour there seems to be two camps like
let's everybody back off let's see what
he can do i'm in that camp and then you
hear those two is just a guy certainly
when you certainly when you'd evaluate
him compared to justin herbert on a
field when you're talking about
professional football which camp are you
in regards to two i'm in the same camp
i've been since before they were drafted
i had herbert as my number one
quarterback because i felt like he was
the biggest the fastest the strongest
the smartest
and if he had played in the sec he would
have been the first pick in the draft so
i've always been very very high on
herbert i love that had he played in the
sec so it was the pac-12 that knocked
him down two pegs in the quarterback
order
behind barrow and two
yeah rich there is such a bias in you
know and justifiably so that sec players
will get boosted up and i've done
studies on this both from a team
standpoint and a media standpoint uh
fair unfair if you play in the sec
that's going to elevate your status and
justin herbert is a guy that attracts no
attention to himself who is a great
player and if they had beaten auburn on
opening day uh his last season he may
have and i predicted that he was going
to be the first pick in the draft when
the heisman and the national title which
is you know the triple crown and they
were close to doing that um and i think
if he had played at scc school not
oregon the narrative around him would
have been completely different all right
and i'll i'll be honest with you mike
i've you know uh i'm i'm a die-hard jet
fan as you know um and i follow this
stuff professionally as you know i
i don't know if i've ever heard that
farv might have gone to tampa instead of
the jets back in the day i've not heard
that one before is that what happened
john gruden was recruiting him john
gruden had coached him in green bay and
was then the head coach at tampa he
lived much closer to tampa named in new
york he didn't know at the time the
offensive coordinator brian schottheimer
the head coach eric mangini or myself
and we were at a competitive
disadvantage and we had to work our
tails off to convince brett that he
could have a great experience in the
woods of new jersey as i kept trying to
recruit him that there is hunting and
fishing in new jersey right and
eventually we were able to convince him
to come well because you had to acquire
him from green bay though right like
he's still
right you still had
so but brett was on his own tour and and
so green bay would have still had sent
him within conference not a problem that
was definitely not a an impediment to
all of that no i think they i think they
certainly would have preferred to trade
him to the afc that was the one thing we
had going for ourselves but obviously we
couldn't make a trade
until we knew that brett was going to
come and not retire okay and that took
several weeks to convince him that he
could have a great experience not only
on the field but it's a great part of
the country and he was not a northeast
guy and he was you know somebody that
was very comfortable in the south so it
took us like i said several weeks to
eventually convince him that if we made
the trade with green bay which they
would prefer to make with us
that uh he would come and play mike
tannenbaum here on the rich eisen show
few more minutes left with the former uh
executive front office executive grocery
shopper capologist and now analyst
do you have me wearing many hats mike
you've worn many many hats so um does
this look like deja vu all over again
for the patriots to you from back in the
day right now or what what do you think
absolutely and i was fortunate to cover
mac jones at the senior bowl for espn
and he reminds me of matt ryan rich he
is
a good not great athlete he has a good
arm not an elite arm but he's smart he
throws with great accuracy and
anticipation
and he's somebody that i think is a
perfect fit for new england because play
action
and precision
the receivers have to be in certain
spots and he will get the ball in time
and i think he's someone that one of the
things that coach belichick rich always
talks about is let the opponent lose the
game before we ever have to win it and
that's something that he does very well
he will not beat himself and i'm
fascinated to watch these two games
against buffalo because if you and i
were talking a month rich yeah i
wouldn't be surprised if the women won
the division this year yeah i know right
i mean
they got the titans too mike like they
they have the teams that they just need
to beat right in front of them and then
they could just go into the playoffs
with as high a seed as they possibly can
get
and um and roll with it i just love that
so we always hear that do your job he's
like let the other team lose it before
you have to win it that's a phrase that
you've heard him say huh
huh yeah multiple times that's one of
his big tenants is like and if we're
gonna lose let's lose by our opponent
beating us left-handed we're gonna take
away what our opponent does great we're
gonna double-team their best player or
whatever it is and if we're gonna lose
let's make our opponent beat us with
their second or third best option mm-hmm
so are you saying if mack jones if the
jets took him second overall he'd be
injured watching flacco right now as
opposed to where he is is that what
you're telling me
is what you're saying
if you don't mind if we can broaden this
discussion somewhat geographically i
think the other interesting discussion
is you know what is kyle shanahan
thinking today okay trey lance compared
to okay jones
go for it right
because like to me
mac jones may wind up being a better
player than trey lance and
the san francisco trade up multiple
first round picks
and i was candidly surprised that they
didn't take matt jones so i thought he
would have been a perfect fit there so
while the jets may have some you know
we'll see how it plays out and look
again it's early but i think how matt
jones is playing is not a fluke also let
me let me let's let's go there i i kind
of dig this and i was just being
facetious obviously about mac jones but
it is the nature versus nurture thing do
you think had had mac jones gone to san
francisco and they had not gotten trey
lance he would have forced the issue
with jimmy g
um and and what we're seeing in new
england
might have been
and again they just flat out released
cam
but they wouldn't have done that with
jimmy g but do you think that that would
have happened
given the opportunity that mac would
have gotten the snaps and we'd be seeing
in san francisco what we're seeing in
new england with mac jones do you think
in my opinion here's how i think it
would have played out i think they would
have released jimmy g and here's why i
think mac jones shows up he wins them
over from day one and kyle shanahan and
john lynch are gonna go by what they see
and they would not have guaranteed jimmy
g's 24 million dollar salary because as
a vested vet when he was on the roster
on opening day they owed him 24 million
and i think from call it june 1st rich
after the draft to
opening day they would have had enough
of a sample size to say we're rolling
with matt jones and they would have
tried to trade but ultimately they would
have cut jimmy g the state in my opinion
to save that 24 million dollars how
about that
isn't that amazing if that's the case
it's amazing mac jones is a
is is is the real deal it's just shown
that um
last one for you who's the first overall
pick in next year's draft how does that
shaping up right now as the college
football season winds down what do you
got for me on that rich that's a simple
question a complicated answer i mean the
best player to be is probably kayvon
thibodeaux from
your neck of the woods la and plays in
oregon and he to me is a similar version
to chase young i just don't think
there's a quarterback that's in that
conversation right now so thibodeau's up
there uh derek stingley the corner from
lsu would probably be a top five pick as
well okay very good thanks for the call
mike and just you know even though you
just what you said you said you know i'm
still a guy from staten island you know
what i mean
[Laughter]
even though i've got it thanks so much
for having me take care of yourself mike
tannenbaum you're the best you'll be
well that's mike tannenbaum good guy hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here